JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS AND
DANA PERINO, "THE FIVE"."
>> Greg: IT WAS A TRIUMPH OF
TAXIDERMY.
>> Dana: ANOTHER VICTORY FOR
JOE BIDEN AND THE REST OF THE
EVENING IS SHAPING UP VERY
NICELY FOR JOE BIDEN.
>> Greg: SO WHAT DID WE LEARN
AMERICA?
FIRST, POLITICS IS LIKE
REAL ESTATE, LOCATION, LOCATION,
LOCATION.
AS FORCEFUL AS BERNIE’S VISION
WAS, IT WAS ON THE WRONG PLACE.
BEING A SOCIALIST IN THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL ECONOMY IS LIKE
TRYING TO SELL BEN & JERRY’S AND
SIBERIA.
HE’S TRYING TO SELL A BAD IDEA
THAT’S TWICE HIS AGE AND SAID,
NO WAY.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE 50 PLUS CROWD
WHO PAY THEIR BILLS WILL MAKE
WISER CHOICES, SURPRISE.
MEANWHILE WITH JOE, THAT
CARDBOARD CONTRAPTION MAY HAVE
STRUCTURAL FLAWS BUT AT LEAST
IT’S STANDING IN THE RIGHT
PLACE.
PLUS, HE REMEMBERED HIS PANTS.
AS ONE WISE MAN ONCE SAID TO
COME PERHAPS YESTERDAY ON THIS
VERY SHOW, DANA, THE DEMS OF
VOTING FOR BIDEN ARE PURCHASING
A TEAR DOWN.
IT’S NOT FOR THE STRUCTURE BUT
THE LAND.
IS IT VP PICK MAY BE IN CHARGE
AT SOME POINT IF HE WINS.
SO THAT’S LIKE SNAPPING UP A
PRIME LOT IN WHICH TO BUILD THE
HARRIS HOME.
THE KLOBUCHAR CASTLE, AND THE
WEAKNESSES OF WHAT THEY ARE LEFT
WITH BECOME MORE APPARENT.
THEY SHOULD HAVE BLASTED SANDERS
EARLY ON BUT THEY LIKED THE LOOK
OF AGREEING ON WITH HIM SO THEY
GOING NOWHERE.
>> I WILL DO EVERYTHING IN MY
POWER TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
ON SUNDAY NIGHT IN THE FIRST ONE
ON ONE DEBATE OF THIS CAMPAIGN,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE WHICH
CANDIDATE IS BEST POSITIONED TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
I VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DEBATE IN ARIZONA WITH MY
FRIEND, JOE BIDEN.
>> Greg: SOLD THE DEMS HAD TWO
CHOICES.
THE RADICALLY WRONG, WHO
HONESTLY REFLECTS THE PARTIES
SECRET SOCIALISM, OR THE
CONVENTIONAL CODGER WHO LIMPED
TO THE FINISH LINE TO DELIVER
SOMEONE YOUNGER AND NEW LIKE
HILLARY.
IT COULD WORK.
WHAT IF THEY DON’T GET BIDEN
PREPPED AND PROPPED BEFORE
TRUMP, IT WILL BE LIKE FEEDING
OLD GROWTH LOGS TO A WOOD
CHIPPER.
ALL RIGHT, BERNIE IS STAYING IN.
JESSIE, DO YOU THINK IT’S A
CONSPIRACY?
HE STAYING IN BECAUSE HE’S NOT
SURE JOE WILL MAKE IT TO THE
END.
BUT TO THE CONVENTION, IF HE
DOESN’T MAKE IT TO THE
COMMISSION THEN BERNIE WILL SAY,
HERE I AM EVERYBODY.
>> Jesse: IS HEDGING HIS BETS.
BUT BEFORE WE GET INTO THIS, YOU
FALLEN IN LOVE WITH THE STARE
DOWN ANALOGY.
YOU WILL USE IT EVERYDAY BEAT
UNTIL THE CONVENTION AND I WILL
BE SICK OF IT.
AMERICA YOU’VE BEEN WARNED.
I THINK IT’S A BIG TEST FOR JOE,
HE’S A TERRIBLE DEBATER AND HE’S
PROBABLY LOST EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THE DEBATES HE’S BEEN IN BUT
IS STILL STANDING.
I DON’T THINK HE’S GOING TO DO
ONE ON ONE WELL AGAINST
BERNIE SANDERS.
I JUST DON’T.
AND I FEEL BAD FOR HIM.
AND I DON’T FEEL BAD FOR
ANYBODY.
I HAVE VERY LITTLE EMPATHY FOR
ANYBODY BUT IT WILL BE A SAD
SITUATION.
HE LOSES HIS TEMPER WITH REGULAR
VOTERS.
HOW WILL HE DO AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP?
TRUMP WILL MAKE HIS HEAD SPIN.
JOE BIDEN, THIS IS NOT
PRESIDENTIAL TIMBER.
HE’S A BAD COMMUNICATOR, ISN’T
THAT SHARP AND HAS BAD
INSTINCTS.
HE DOESN’T HAVE WHAT IT TAKES.
HE WAS IN THE SENATE FOR 36
YEARS, HE WAS VP FOR EIGHT YEARS
YEARS.
>> Dana: I DON’T EVEN THINK
HE’S RUNNING.
>> Jesse: THAT’S RIGHT.
HIS SON IS STIFFING HIS BABY
MAMA AND BLAMED IT ON
CORONAVIRUS.
NOT A GOOD LOOK FOR JOE.
BUT BERNIE, BERNIE HAD HIS BACK
AGAINST THE WALL AND DIDN’T
THROW A PUNCH.
I THINK EVERYBODY WATCHING HIM
KNOWS THAT ONCE YOU PRAISE
COMMUNISM THERE’S NO WAY TO BEAT
DONALD TRUMP.
BLACK AMERICA WENT WITH JOE AND
THAT WAS ALL SHE WROTE.
BERNIE HAD NO CHANCE TO BEAT
DONALD TRUMP.
JOE BIDEN HAD BETTER THAN NO
CHANCE BUT THAT’S STILL NOT A
VERY GOOD CHANCE.
THE ONLY THING YOU COULD SAY
ABOUT JOE IS HE SAVED HIS PARTY
FROM SOCIALISM.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK
NANCY, ANY STRONG PREDICTIONS?
>> EVEN IF BIDEN DOES A HORRIBLE
JOB AGAINST SANDERS, WHICH HE
WELCOME IT DOESN’T MATTER.
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS AND
COALESCE AND CONGEAL AROUND
BIDEN.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT SANDERS HAS
PASSION.
HE BELIEVES THAT EVEN THOUGH IT
IS SOCIALISM LIKE CUBA.
BUT I DON’T THINK BIDEN HAS ANY
CLUE ABOUT WHAT’S GOING ON.
NOW IF JILL BIDEN RAN, THERE
MIGHT BE AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
STORY.
>> Greg: GEL CAN JUMP ON STAGE
AND KNOCK THEM DOWN.
>> Jesse: HE IS A DOCTOR AND
WE NEED A DOCTOR IN THESE TRYING
TIMES, WHAT’S YOUR ANALYSIS?
>> Juan: IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
JOE BIDEN HAD A GREAT NIGHT LAST
NIGHT.
I DON’T THINK THERE’S MUCH OF A
WAY THAT YOU COULD CONCEIVE OF
HIM NOT BEING THE NOMINEE AT
THIS JUNCTURE.
BUT I DO THINK THAT EVEN THOUGH
YOU HAVE THE LEAD AND THE BALL
YOU CAN FUMBLE.
OR YOU CAN THROW AN
INTERCEPTION.
WAS THAT, I THINK, WAS IT THE
SEATTLE SEAHAWKS THROUGH AN
INTERCEPTION DOWN THE ONE-YARD
LINE?
SO THESE THINGS DO HAPPEN.
BUT YOU ARE SAYING ABOUT
JOE BIDEN REMINDS ME OF WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT JOE BIDEN WAY BACK.
HE’S MADE SO MANY MISTAKES, HE’S
A STIFF, HE CAN’T DEBATE, BUT
JOE BIDEN IS DOING PRETTY GOOD.
>> Greg: THAT’S BECAUSE OF THE
CONGEALING.
>> Juan: THE DEMOCRATIC VOTERS
ARE NOT CONGEALING.
REAL PEOPLE WENT AND CAST THEIR
VOTE.
>> Jesse: THEY CONFUSED MAN
WITH THE COMMUNIST.
>> Juan: PROVEN UPSTANDING
DECENT CITIZEN IN DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: GIVE US YOUR
EXPERTISE.
>> Dana: IT BIDEN WENT TO
MICHIGAN ONCE AND WON’T WANT
EVERY SINGLE COUNTY IN MICHIGAN,
HIGHER MARGINS THAN IN 2016 THAT
AND I THINK THAT EVERYBODY
SHOULD LOOK AT 2016.
THE DEMOCRATS IN THEIR ZEAL FOR
BERNIE SANDERS, BECAUSE HE HAS
PASSION AND HE HAS THESE IDEAS.
HE FEELS LIKE HE HAS TO DEBATE
THE IDEAS.
THE TRUTH IS I DON’T THINK THE
DEMOCRATS WERE AS FAR LEFT AT
SOME OF US WERE THINKING.
THEY JUST COULD NOT STAND
HILLARY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THESE BREAKDOWNS,
WHITE MEN VOTED FOR BERNIE IN
2016.
THEY ALL WENT FOR BIDEN IN 2020
BECAUSE I DID NOT LIKE THE
CHOICE BETWEEN ERNIE AND
HILLARY.
SO THAT LESSON WAS NOT LEARNED.
NOW YOU HAVE BIDEN WHO, NOW YOU
HAVE TO GO TO A DEBATE TO DEBATE
THESE IDEAS OF BERNIE SANDERS
THAT HAVE BEEN REJECTED ACROSS
THE COUNTRY BY DEMOCRATS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY VOTING.
>> Greg: TO THAT POINT, I HAVE
SOME SOUND ON TAPE OF BERNIE
TALKING ABOUT HOW HIS WINNING
THE GENERATIONAL BATTLE, LET’S
PLAY THAT, FOR THE HECK OF IT.
>> WE ARE WINNING THE
GENERATIONAL DEBATE, WITH OLDER
AMERICANS, ESPECIALLY THOSE
PEOPLE OVER 65.
OUR CAMPAIGN CONTINUES TO WIN
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE VOTES
OF YOUNGER PEOPLE.
AND I AM TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
NOT JUST IN THEIR 20s BUT IN
THEIR 30s AND THEIR 40s.
A >> Dana: WHILE THE THING IS,
YOU CAN HAVE A MOVEMENT, THAT’S
GREAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE TO HAVE A
MOVEMENT OR TWO PER DAY.
[LAUGHS]
I’M JUST FRUSTRATED WITH THIS
WHOLE THING WITH BERNIE SANDERS,
IT’S SO AMAZING.
YOU HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT COME
TO YOUR RALLIES AND THEY WILL
VOTE FOR YOU BUT IN THESE TINY
LITTLE NUMBERS, IT DOESN’T
MATTER.
THERE ARE OLDER VOTERS BUT THEY
CHOSE SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> Greg: MTV STARTED ROCK THE
VOTE AND NOW THOSE ARE THE OLDER
VOTERS AND THEY ARE ROCKING THE
BOAT.
>> Juan: IT’S WITH WHAT
BERNIE SANDERS IS TRUE, HE WON
THE VOTERS 18 AND EVEN UNDER 45.
BUT TO REITERATE WHAT DANA JUST
SAID TO COME THEY DIDN’T TURN
OUT.
HE CAN GO AFTER TRADE POLICY OR
HEALTH CARE, AND A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO AGREE
WITH HIM BUT ULTIMATELY AS HE
SAID TO COME THEY DON’T AGREE
THAT HE IS THE BEST CANDIDATE TO
BEAT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Jesse: AND IT ALSO HURTS
HIM WHEN HE BRINGS OMAR ON STAGE